die abgründe in dem neu aufgedeckten
missbrauchsskandal werden immer tiefer
das zeigt sich wie sehr die pädophilen
szene in deutschland vernetzt ist und
wie skrupellos sie vorgeht millionen
fotos und videos von brutal
missbrauchten babys und kleinkindern
wurden ausgetauscht einfach widerlich
es ist ein missbrauchs komplex über den
ermittler sagen er kann zum größten der
deutschen geschichte werden 33 kleine
opfer gequält und vergewaltigt von 73
männern die sich deutschlandweit
vernetzen anstacheln und motivieren
kinder und säuglinge zu missbrauchen an
der spitze marcus r it-experte über
jahre führte ein doppelleben zu hause
gibt er den harmlosen ehemann doch auf
seinem computer hatte der gigantische
mengen kinderpornografie missbraucht
kinder auf brutalste weise und baut über
jahre ein pädophilen netzwerk auf doch
wie konnte es so weit kommen und wie
furchtbar sind die ausmaße der
verbrechen des marcus r
seit 1993 speichert der 44-jährige
it-experte kinderpornografie auf seine
privatrechner 1,5 millionen videos 3,5
millionen bilder von vergewaltigungen
junger kinder und babys in vielen fällen
filmt er die taten selbst das ausmaß
seiner abstoßenden sammlung ist enorm
markus erfurt listen um den überblick
nicht zu verlieren
die ermittler wissen jetzt bereits 2005
hat markus er kinder missbraucht bis
2019 vergewaltigt er 18 kinder doch
markus er beginnt seine straftaten nicht
allein kontinuierlich baute er seine
pädophilen netzwerk auf und beschafft
sich komplizen für seine verbrechen
einer davon ist sönke die ausbilden mehr
als 17.000 nachrichten sollen die beiden
über das verschlüsselte chat portal spox
ausgetauscht haben senden sich fotos und
videos ihrer taten wie auch markus er
soll sind kg anzeigen als babysitter
geschaltet haben und betreuungsdienste
für behinderte kinder angeboten haben
sind ggs preis 5 euro pro stunde im
grunde möchte ich einfach gerne meine
fähigkeiten gut mit kindern umzugehen
anbieten ich möchte familien
unterstützen ein möglichst entspanntes
familienleben zu haben markus er uns
sind gegen einen windel fetisch der
wermelskirchener schaltet sich bei sönke
gs vergewaltigung zweimal dazu die
schreie der klein opfer soll der
berliner laut polizei vermerken mit ein
bisschen ja man ist immer kommentiert
haben unfassbar im februar 2009 10 soll
markus er nach berlin gereist sein und
so mpg besucht haben es soll ein treffen
im zugegeben haben sind gg soll markus
er eines seiner opfer einen geistig
behinderten siebenjährigen jungen
überlassen haben markus er kontakte
reichen sogar bis in den münster
missbrauchs komplex im juni 2020
sprechen ermittler einen der größten
pädophilen ringe in der deutschen
geschichte mehr als 50 männer
missbrauchte und vergewaltigte
unschuldige kleine kinder über jahre in
einer gartenlaube in münster und anderen
orten in deutschland an der spitze des
münsteraner missbrauchs komplex adrian v
bereits verurteilt zu 14 jahren haft
markus er stand auch mit ihm in kontakt
gab adrian v anweisungen wie der
straftäter kinder vergewaltigen soll
aufgrund von datenschutz verordnungen
können die beamten markus r im rahmen
der damaligen ermittlungen nicht
identifizieren monate lang an der
44-jährige weitere straftaten begehen
bis zum august 2021 ermittler nehmen
sönke g in berlin fest zuvor finden
eltern eines von sönke betreuten kindes
kinderpornografie auf seinem handy der
berliner kooperiert mit den behörden
hilft den ermittlern sind igs mit täter
zu identifizieren
er selbst sitzt inzwischen im berliner
knast zwölf jahre mit anschließender
sicherheitsverwahrung ein ähnliches
strafmaß kann auch markus er erwarten
seitdem ihn die ermittler am dritten
dezember 2021 festnahmen sitzt er in
untersuchungshaft
erst zehn prozent von markus erst
kinderpornografie material sichteten die
ermittler bereits 73 tatverdächtige
konnten identifiziert werden die polizei
ermittelt weiter unter hochdruck um alle
pädophilen täter zu fassen